foreign
crisis has helped deteriorate our
property values if you combine that with
uh eviction moratorium and um other
government policies we have a situation
now where the property values that
people are plummeting
homelessness in Oakland it's not just
home assisted what you think of where
people who are poor are forced to live
on the street because they can't afford
rent
that's part of it but big part of
Oakland's homeless crisis are open-air
drug market and uh permissiveness of RV
parking and basically
um anything goes for selling drugs and
it's created unlivable situation it's
created RVs being able to park on our
streets anywhere they want to we have a
72 hour parking lot in Oakland that is
regularly broken
um and so now you have a situation where
a homelessness that's exploded it's gone
from about 3 000 people in 2018 to
upwards of ten thousand
so what we've created is that Oakland
and San Francisco have become the
promised land of milk conventional and
people are coming here uh and Studies
have shown it now we've seen studies
that are finally
proven what people here have known for
years people who are homeless in Okinawa
typically are not fun here they're drug
tourists and they're coming here for the
uh safe and easy access to their drug of
choice and the ability to also still to
support those habits because there's no
rule of law and that's where the
intersection between these drugs the
staff the reach out that they're all
connected so we have
a very intense organized crime uh
entrenchment in the city of Oakland
right now when it comes to our
livability
so if you're in close proximity to a
homeless Camp your business or your home
or residence let's say the business I
don't mean the individual insurance but
the actual person who owns the building
they can't get insurance down if it's by
an encampment they've got to get Top
Flight super expensive insurance and of
course that used to wear their bottom
line eventually they're going to make
decisions to style and leave the city so
it's creating a very uh untenable
situation when it comes to our ability
to have a healthy and thriving business
community
the more businesses are impacted and
leave the less taxes they pay the more
affluent upperly mobile people who have
the disposable income and resources move
the less taxes you have and then you are
stuck in a situation like New York City
in the early 80s or Detroit and other
West belt cities currently so there's no
reason for that to happen we have
pictures whether we have the the
neighborship we have people here who are
very skilled we have people here who
have want to own businesses who want to
engage in entrepreneurship we have
people who would love to invest in
Oakland but as long as our current
politics our our new progressives are in
charge who've seen hell-bent on on this
policy no one's going to come here